Football is played on a rectangular pitch marked out by touchlines and goal lines.
Play starts with a kickoff from the center circle.
A goal consists of two upright posts supporting a horizontal crossbar,...
...lines on the pitch mark the goal area and the penalty box.
Each side must have no more than 11 players on the pitch including a goalkeeper.
Positions change according to tactics.
To score a goal, the ball must cross the goal line inside the goalmouth.
However, it can be disallowed if the scorer is offside when he receives the ball.
A player is offside if he's close to the opponent's goal...
...than both the ball and the second-last opponent.
If a player kicks the ball out of play, a throw-in is taken by the opposing team.
A corner kick is awarded when the ball crosses the opposition goal line...
...after last touching one of their players.
It's taken from the corner of whichever side the ball left the field.
Free kicks are awarded to teams for fouls and misconduct outside the penalty area.
They're taken from the spot where the offense occurred.
Players from the opposing team often form a wall between the ball and the goal.
If a foul occurs within the penalty area,...
...the referee awards a penalty.
The defending goalkeeper must remain on his goal line until the ball's been kicked.